[Musique]
le jour
autre
[Musique]
e
à
les vols
[Musique]
voilà donc aujourd'hui aussi un petit
extrait de la cérémonie on va le mieux
compris voilà pour vous c'est une
ineptie dans ton qu'il fallait pas
célébrer napoléon à je suis très content
de voir que le président et que brigitte
soit aller aller au bal ce n'est pas le
paria les invalides
c'était l'abcès là ça fait très
longtemps comme un président en vain
chirac n'a pas célébré en 2004 2005 le
sacré et austerlitz après y'a rien eu
donc franchement c'est ça me fait
plaisir que le président et que un très
beau discours à l'institut donc oui je
suis très très heureux moi ce show sur
eux alors gilbert date pour nous il
fallait pas le célébrer napoléon pas du
tout neil commémorer nil célébrer parce
que c'est la même chose
non franchement il a rétabli l'esclavagé
c'est un boucher il faut s'intéresser à
napoléon mais il a fait travailler les
esclaves dans les sucreries au nom de l'
empire colonial français
c'est une honte ce qu'on fait
aujourd'hui on devrait s'excuser d'avoir
eu napoléon dans notre patrimoine
historique 7h18 sont deux oui un texte
il rétablit l'esclavagé en martinique en
guadeloupe en guyane alors qu'il avait
été abolie par après la révolution par
la convention 8 794 faudra ensuite
attendre 1848 pour que l'esclave assoit
définitivement abolie et puis on va
parler des autres peau des autres
polémiques autour de napoléon 1 l'année
dernière souvenez vous il y avait un
grand débat aussi sur colbert le monde
2014 qui est à l'origine du code noir et
c'est vrai que voilà à chaque fois on se
demandait ce qu'on doit célébrer ces
gens ou pas gaulle bears avaient posé
polémiste éléments l'air d'affoler on
sent encore plus sympa ce que napoléon
ça reste c'est le sait le personnage
conseil jura
voilà exactement et le plus recherché
sachez le chaque année sur les réseaux
en napoléon voilà il croit avoir cette
année encore plus bien entendu valérie
benaïm mais contrairement à gilles moi
je pense que commémorer célébrer ce
n'est pas du tout la même chose vraiment
un sens en france commémorer ça veut
dire que c'est un personnage une figure
qui a marqué l'histoire de france et à
ce titre là hebron décrypte avec à la
fois évidemment sa part d'ombré qui est
immense parce que ça a été effectivement
un boucher qui l'a mis l'europe à feu et
à sang qu'il était comme on le dit
aujourd'hui effectivement
il a remis aux esclavagistes lavage
risme qu'il était antisémite et c'est
vous dire une chose valérie benaïm
xavier différence autres commémorer et
célébrer oui c'est ce qu'a dit
d'ailleurs le chef de l'état tout ça se
regarde et vous traversez le pont
d'austerlitz ou d'iéna parcouru la rue
de rivoli ses chefs d'oeuvre
d'architecturé d'urbanisme toutes ces
références nous les devons aussi à
napoléon
c'est ce qui fait que nous sommes
rassemblés ce jour non pas pour nous
livrer à une célébration exalté comme le
site en 1840 le peuple de paris au
retour des cendres de l'empereur mais
pour une commémoration
éclairez moi je pense qu'effectivement
il faut à la fois justement expliqué qui
est le personnage et ne peut absolument
pas mettre sous le tapis tout l'aspect
négatif du personnage tout la part
d'ombré du personnage parce qu'elle est
évidemment très importante mais en même
temps parce que c'est pour le coup c'est
vraiment le en même temps c'est il est à
l'origine du code civil est à l'origine
des préfets il est à l'origine de
l'hélice les du baccalauréat et c'est
alexis alexis corbière fallait pas le
commémorer
alors si je veux pas jouer sur les mots
mais ça vient d'être dit pas par les
chroniqueurs il faut parler de napoléon
en france c'est bien on aime l'histoire
est évidemment que c'est un personnage
important et ce serait une folie
d'imaginer qu'on parle pas de ce
personnage
maintenant moi le problème que j'ai à
partiront le président de la république
prend la parole je dis pas les
historiens les historiens ils doivent
parler il ya des expositions de ton lieu
ce que ceux qui nous regardent
allez-y si passionnant l'histoire de
france mais moi ce qui m'intéresse c'est
le grand événement c'est la révolution
française c'est la première fois près
700 ans de monarchie
le peuple se mobilise il ya la
république est mis en place l'idée de la
souveraineté populaire pas seulement
monarque héréditaire et ça c'est une
expérience fabuleuse que napoléon arrête
et c'est le fossoyeur de la république
et la révolution en 17 ans 4 à 19 il
prend le pouvoir avec un coup d'état
militaire a pas tort l'enseigné
aujourd'hui c'est que les promesses de
la révolution elles sont encore
d'actualité
liberté égalité fraternité on a voulu
écrire sur les murs de nos écoles c'est
pas encore le cas c'est ça qu'il faut
garder et lui napoléon si celui qui va
concentrer le pouvoir entre les mains
d'un seul homme qui va prendre le
pouvoir 1799 d'abord y est premier
consul peu après il se fait sacrer
empereur il va rétablir une noblesse
noblesse d'empyr l'esclavagé au monde
mais quand même des gens si sur ce que
vous
10 série d'annoncés la révolution
française aboli l'esclavagé en 1794 ceux
qui nous écoutent ils savent qu'en 1789
qui la révolution ont déclaré droits de
l'homme et du citoyen article les hommes
naissent et demeurent libres et égaux en
droit de penser ce qui est normalement
on a oublié ce cash et ben non et il
faut cinq ans que les esclaves eux mêmes
notamment à saint domingue fasse une
révolution dans la révolution pour aboli
l esclavage
donc ça prend du temps et dans le
contexte de l'époque parce qu'on nous
reproche parfois de dire ouais mais tu
décontextualisés c'est des sujets
d'aujourd'hui mais non mais à l'époque
c'est une avancée c'est là où la france
elle parle au monde entier où on est
universaliste danton le en 94 il dit
nous abolissons ou la voulte esclavage
dans le monde entier et lui le rétablit
donc il est en réaction par rapport à
l'époque et ça comme il y avait des
lycéens aujourd'hui qui moi j'ai envie
de chercher ça que j'ai envie de dire
aux jeunes
attention notre histoire c'est le combat
qu'on doit continuer à mener c'est que
la promesse de la révolution il faut
encore l'appliquer taire le peuple
souverain paul monarque et j'ai envie de
dire que ça c'est encore d'actualité
parce qu'il ya dans la vie politique son
appel le bonapartisme l'idée comme quand
le pays va mal et peut-être qu'ils font
des confier le pouvoir un homme fort qui
va régler nos problèmes
ça ça m'inquiète on a encore vu
récemment la 15 jours des militaires qui
ont dit bave le plan mais sur la paix
l'insurrection des militaires aussi
voilà non mais tu penses que ce que je
veux dire c'est qu'on a eu dans
l'histoire de france vite à chaque fois
on se dit il faut un homme fort
justement alors que ce pour vous se
ferait le contraire
mais voilà maintenant mais il faut pas
des gens faibles mais je dire il faut
des institutions ce qu'il faut renforcer
ses des institutions démocratiques qui
donne le pouvoir au peuple
vous avez invité des gilet jaune et je
vous en remercie pour ça que je vous
aime bien mais qu'est ce qu'ils veulent
ces gens qui sont à l'image du peuple
français plus de droits plus de pouvoirs
il n'empêche pas l'autre le coq jamais
le l'empereur lui c'est la gontrie b200
historique et en même temps de dire
effectivement tout ce que vous venez de
dire la faille parti qu'il fallait qu'il
faille parler d'histoire c'est une
évidence moi j'aime pas les gens qui
veulent enlever les stages sur lille et
à roubaix son groupe ont pu rien et
noblement je suis prof d'histoire mais
s'en faut la pompe ce serait dingue de
dirhams non j'en parle pas parce qu'ils
me préparais à lille il faut l'appeler
en parler totalement de meilleures
jambes ce que moi il ya une chose qui me
dérange pas ce qu il fait déjà
il faut rappeler que c'est lui c'est ce
qu'a déclaré qu'à signer le débat de la
déclaration des droits de l'homme
c'est luis saez qui signe en bas
regardez le document original vous allez
voir c'est signé par louis xiii
parce que 2007 il a deux
ça et puis on lui a fait ça et ça bon
bref en tout cas ça a été signée par lui
c'est cette fois soit débattue au
parlement avec la caa
non mais ces émissions non et après le
ski dit intéressant parce qu'il est en
train de dire pardon je pense que je
vais pas parler vous vous exprimez ce
que lui ça c'est un homme éclairant
c'est la monarchie constitutionnelle
dans un premier temps c'est ça qu'il
faut comprendre que les événements ils
avancent en 1789 il ya encore la
monarchie elle est constitutionnelle et
parce que le roi selon moi ne respecte
pas ses engagements après en 92 ans
proclame la république c'est ça qui fera
pendant nos jeunes c'est que c'est des
processus qui prennent du temps
il suffit pas de proclamer des droits et
dire les hommes naissent et demeurent
libres et égaux en droits pour qu'on
abolisse le score par genre n'emportez
coton la table si je descendis balle
mais il ya une dernière chose mais dans
son corps aux bières excusez moi je mets
mes lectures
il faut rappeler quand même aussi moi
j'adore je lis tout mais il faut quand
même rappeler qu'à l'époque c'était le
dieu est le roi et quand vous parlez de
la république
mais la république déjà là fait crever
louis 17 dans une prison ils ont tués
combien de deux de nos deux prêtres dans
les abbayes et c'est la naissance de la
république ça aiderait aussi un génocide
donc quand on prend les cieux non c'est
pas ça les regarde et on a quand même un
pays où on a la chance de regarder en
face civisme à génocide génocide sans
mots forts en france il ya eu un
génocide dans l'histoire de l'humanité
et le génocide des juifs d'accord ça ça
a existé et l'arménie on peut en parler
il ya eu des massacres n'est pas le mot
génocide ou ne banalisons pas ce mot il
n'y a pas eu une volonté de draguer une
dation final combien de sur napoléon
mais ce que je veux dire c'est que le
mot il faut pas le banaliser a bien fait
si ce que dit alexis pour vous quand
vous entendez des gens dire qu'il
fallait pas commémorer napoléon mais non
il faut bien sûr qu'il fallait
collaborer napoléon et et napoléon a
fait quand même des choses
extraordinaires napoléon c'est une
galaxie le problème c'est qu'on veut
toujours faire du micro et bien apple on
regarde pas avec un micro on le regarde
son activité on va pas le célébrer on va
le commémorer mais ça veut dire quelque
chose oui ça veut dire qu'il veut pas
aller trop loin non plus ouais il fit
mais moi ça me va très bien cette cette
commémoration de d'aujourd'hui mais on
nous parle de l'esclavagisme et tu sais
que napoléon
la première chose quand ils reviennent
l'île d'elbe le premier décret quand ils
arrivent au dessus il rit le 29 mars
1815 et bien ici lalala lalala
l'abrogation de la traite des [ __ ]
c'est un truc très important c'est une
combine politicienne en tout petit par à
sainte hélène
on va à sainte hélène il est en exil il
ya un esclave qui s'appelle toby qui est
un esclave à d'origine africaine il se
prend d'amitié pour lui et il le voyez
il parle il lui donna à 1 euro un homme
n est qu un gros machin me louis les
sympathies les modernes et et au bout
d'un moment il dit c'est insupportable
je veut racheter la liberté de cet homme
il va la payer très cher
et cet homme va être libre l'apollon
c'est ça alors naples on est sûr c'est
un homme de droit c'est un homme de
d'ordre et il pouvait pas supporter
après l'arrêt vous dérange en sauce et
je vous aime bien mais c'est passionnant
ça c'est pas sérieux de ne parler s'ils
ont chaud quand on rétablit la ccva si
on envoie trente mille hommes
trente mille hommes pour faire la guerre
à ceux qui sont abolis c'est pas parce
que quinze ans plus tard il un serviteur
noire elle est sympa la mode ça me
rappelle des gens racistes qu'ils ont
acheté noir je suis sentie accord sais
pas je suis avec toi lui fait la guerre
contre les états qui se sentiraient
l'argent les examens en fait tu sais
pourquoi il part à saint domingue avec
ses troupes et d'ailleurs sont son beau
frère va mourir le général leclerc y
avait mille français qui meurt il prenne
une rouste hausse des prix s'est pris
une claque parce qu'ils sont tous morts
du choléra dutil fait de la guerre c'est
pourquoi il est parti là-bas easy s'en
foutait de saint domingue
il voulait simplement faire une tête de
pont pour la seule la louisiane les
etats unis gardent la france était
propriétaire de la moitié des états unis
où ils ont dû et voilà et ce tournage
et c'est pour ça qu'on bonaparte
s'aperçoit que y'a plus d'armée il a pu
correct expéditionnaire il rappelle sa
soeur pauline borghèse paponi benard
leclerc qui revient il dit maintenant
que c'est terminé et yvan la louisiane
donc napoléon c'est un homme d'ordre et
il avait rien à faire pour lui c'était
c'était secondaire ces choses là etc il
ait fait venir les milliers d'esclaves
et tu dis tu dis un moment que d'appeler
ou bonaparte et bien affaire coût des
taxes et du tout le 2 décembre 1804 il a
été proclamé empereur de la république
française
le 5000 cet oxymore c'est à dire l'idée
de mettre deux choses contradictoires
être empereur et l école c'est comme si
je suis le dictateur démocratique ça
veut rien dire l'empereur de la
république savait rien n'ira sergent
challans heures mais là je vais vous
donner le point napoléon est un génie de
la propagande bat un génie c'est un type
qui le pont d'arcole je sais pas ce qui
n'aura le savent
le tableau et le goût drapeau qui total
ça n'est jamais arrivé j'avais fumé du
pot il a failli se noyer toute équipe
l'ont sorti de l'eau sinon un mur une
moyenne et il a fait des tableaux il dit
ah c'est david c'est toute une semaine
grande pop qui nous montre comme un
personnage magnifique
il raconte ses récits il était sur scène
ou des fêtes en egypte mieux commencer
donc c'est la propagande politique à une
époque où il n'y avait pas cyril hanouna
mais il y avait le louis david lecomte
un peu le cyril hanouna des potes
l'accord celui qui faisait des émissions
non mais c'est sa déraison samedi à une
modernité
il était né au laos au père jean louis
jean louis merci qu'il faut pas qu'il
faut pas oublier moi je vais faire je
vais faire ma féministe ce soir c'est
qu'avec les femmes les femmes avec lui
n'avait pas voir travailler les ai pas
le droit de le droit de vote solennel
par le travail et ce sans l'accord de
leur mari elles n'avaient aucun droit de
disposer de leur salaire et elle n'est
pas le droit de le droit de vote c'est
pas grand chose de super match n'a rien
à voir nous nous a quittés aujourd'hui
avec ce nom qui se passe à l'épaule fine
toi tu pense qu'il faut des falaises
libre et demi pour pour moi ces
commémorations qu'on déteste ou qu'on
adore justement napoléon en fait c'est
juste de la culture générale c'est pour
que les jeunes aussi s'y intéressent
contre la france
voilà notre histoire la france pour
qu'on n'oublie pas l'histoire et qu'on
en tire des leçons lui mais madame la
levée laser la république s'est exprimé
là dessus
par exemple moi je suis républicain mais
il faut connaître les rois de france moi
je vais voter les cathédrales voilà bon
mais quand le président de la république
prend la parole il dit autre chose
seulement peu faut connaître ses
célèbres où ils commémorent et choix
quand il traitait des musulmans les deux
mots ce mélange mais c'est à dire qu'il
dit aux français
ça c'est important ou alors ça n'a pas
de sens ça parle moi ce que j'ai trouvé
aujourd'hui c'est qu'à force de faire du
et en même temps
c'est pas très bien aller qui veut nous
dire j'aurais président alors je vous
dis un truc sans faire trop le malin
c'est qu'il ya même il ya 100 ans en
1921 lors du premier centenaire le
prénom la réplique de l'époque
s'appelait me le rend il n'avait pas
voulu célébrer parce que déjà il y avait
un débat pour dire cantonner des
publicains on peut passer l'elysée
l'emploi mais la fronde obsédé pas fait
son devoir de mémoire mais non mais si
au contraire on parlait napoléon bible
non mais ça s'est vite et d'avoir même
ont suivi comme les allemands avec nos
trois métiers comme quoi aujourd'hui on
pouvait pas parler d'histoire c'est du
baratin parce que depuis toujours on
polémique en france sur l'histoire
depuis deux siècles parce qu'on aime
l'histoire si derrière
non mais je dis revoir et et il suffit
qu'on prenne position qu'on critique
pour que l'on me dit ouais mais toi tu
aimes pas l'histoire de france entre ça
me passionne ça m'énerve ça mais il ya
plein de gens qui auraient coûté encore
jessica lexique non mais je suis de
prendre une chaîne de télévision comme
comme ces news cet après midi durant
l'hommage a aidé à remonter il ya un
gars qui a dit sur le plateau il ya des
gars comme cordelle parler de moi qui
déteste l'histoire de france face aux
critiques des enseignants qui ont dit ça
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
mais ce que je veux dire c'est que
critique et 11 ont expliqué ce qu'ils
disent quand même le bien prenez avec l'
esclavage soi-disant une méprise rennes
l'histoire de france alors que c'est
parce que j'aime l'histoire de france et
qu'il faut être fier d'être français
on est le prix premier pays au monde à
avoir aboli l'esclavagé aucun pays ne
faisait même les états unis d'amérique
avait accordé esclaves donc on devrait
être fiers et dire nous le grand pays en
1794 on a aboli l'esclavagé à entière de
redescendre elle est là elle n'est pas
du côté de lyon c'est bien au delà de
l'esclavagé mais toi tu l'as d'or tu as
des tableaux 3 canal+ on va manger on va
manger des des tacos 3 vient bien sûr
pas le palais des vierges et je vous ai
dit les buissons palinges encore nous
attendre
[Applaudissements]
il est
[Rires]
oui à 64% non à 36 pts